Apple's iPhone event just ended and they
in veiled three new iPhones the iPhone
11:11 Pro and 11 Pro Macs and while that
naming schema is pretty terrible I don't
even care because the pro is gonna be a
complete game-changer
yes the notch is still there yes the
Lightning port is still there but other
than that basically everything else is
on a whole new level first off I was a
little bit worried about the square
camera bump rumors but Apple totally
nailed it with their design the entire
back of the whole phone including the
bump is machined out of one solid piece
of glass and it's now in a textured
matte finish so it won't be a
fingerprint magnet Apple also said it's
the toughest glass and any smartphone so
we'll have to see about that and there's
also a new color midnight green which
I'm personally gonna order so if you
want to hear my thoughts on that color
subscribe right now the Apple logo has
also moved down to the center of the
phone right in front of the wireless
charging coil and the iPhone tech is now
gone offering a cleaner look the problem
with the iPhone 10's is that it looked
and felt exactly the same as the iPhone
10 other than the larger 6.5 inch tennis
max model which is the only reason why I
upgraded and that's why more people will
upgrade to the iPhone 11 pro it looks
and feels much different but the biggest
reasons why it's not a disappointment
are the new chip and the cameras but
before that let's quickly mention a few
standout features the display is now
brighter while being 15% more energy
efficient the speakers are upgraded with
spatial audio surround sound in Dolby
Atmos support the 11pro now finally
comes with an 18 watt USB see charging
adapter in the box and not only that but
the 11pro gets up to 4 hours more
battery life than the 10 s and the 11pro
max gets up to 5 hours longer than the
10s max water resistance is now rated
ip68 up to a maximum of 4 meters instead
of 2 meters on the iPhone 10 s it also
gets Wi-Fi 6 faster LTE and a brand new
Apple u one location chip face ID is now
30% faster and it works from further
away and that greater angles so it's
less likely to miss all of these
features are already seriously
impressive but now let's get into the
brand new
13 Bionic chip is built on Apple's
second-generation 7 nanometer process
with the two performance cores in the
CPU now 20% faster while using 40% less
power and the for efficiency cores are
now 20% faster while using 25% less
power the GPU is now 20% faster while
using 30% less power and the story is
the same for the third general engine
20% faster and 15% more efficient and
the brand new machine learning
accelerators allow the CPU to perform
over 1 trillion operations a second
there's also a new power management unit
that makes sure it's only running at
full power when it needs to so I'm
almost certain that this 8:13 chip will
outperform even next year's Android
flagship phones so it's one of the
reasons why the iPhone 11 pro is not
disappointing at all and now let's get
into the cameras we now get a new ultra
wide lens that can be used to take
photos or shoot in any other video modes
including 4k 60fps the telephoto lens
has been upgraded to an F 2.0 aperture
which means it takes in 40% more light
than before so portrait photos will turn
out much better the wide camera gets a
new 12 megapixel sensor that's a hundred
percent covered with autofocus points
and we now get a new night mode that
automatically turns on when it's dark
and allows for manual fine-tuning of the
shutter and this year we get second
generation smart HDR for even better
dynamic range and photos which was
already impressive on the 10s max and
now there's a new quick take feature
allowing you to hold the shutter button
to instantly start recording video you
get extended dynamic range at up to 60
frames per second in video recording and
a new audio zoom feature that makes sure
you can hear the subject you're pointing
at the best part is that you can swap
between any of the three lenses while
recording video and the exposure focus
and white balance won't change at all
when you swap lenses and even better
Apple showed off the upcoming app filmic
Pro that's able to record video using
multiple lenses at the same time which
was previously unheard of the quality of
the front-facing camera has almost
doubled from 7 megapixels to 12 so you
get super high quality selfies that also
use 2nd gen smart HDR
the iPhone 10s could shoot 1080p video
at 60 frames per second the 11pro can
now shoot 4k selfie video at up to 60fps
which is insane not only that but the
selfie camera can now shoot 1080p slow
motion video at 120 frames per second so
with all those features combined I can
definitely say that the iPhone 11 pro is
the furthest thing from a disappointment
pre-orders start at 5 a.m. this Friday
and we'll be getting our hands on our
iPhone 11 pros on September 20th so if
you're not already subscribed you should
click that circle above so you don't
miss out on our comparison videos thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next one
[Music]